تصدر فلم الخلاط بلص واللي بيعتبر اول عمل
سعودي من انتاجنا فليكس قائمه الافلام ال
10 الاكثر مشاهده في السعوديه خلال
الاسبوع الاول من عرضه كان الخلاط بلس من
ضمن كائن قائمه اكثر 10 افلام مشاهده على
منصه نتفليكس على مستوى العالم وسجل مليون
و500,000 او اكثر من مليون و500,000 ساعه
مشاهده
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله ابليسك
اوف ولا كلمه اوص اتكلم كلمه برميه
[موسيقى]
بالتعاون مع شركه التلفاز 11 وهو اول عمل
للمخرج السعودي فهد العماري وبيشارك في
بطوله عدد من نجوم السعوديه مثل عبد
العزيز الشهري وابراهيم الحجاج
وغيرهم وبيقدم الفيلم خلال ساعتين حكايات
واحداث متنوعه عشان كده تم تسميته الخلاط
تكون القصص متنوعه وبتجمع مشاعر وتفاصيل
مختلفه وفي اربعه حكايات مبنيه على مبدا
الحيله وبيستخدم الفيلم مثل العربي القديم
اللي يعبر عن هذه الحيل وهي او المثل هو
من كان لديه حيله فل يحتال
عن كواليس واجواء فيلم الخلاط كلاسين نظم
الينا من الرياض منتج الفيلم محمد
القرعاوي اهلا فيك معانا محمد كيف حالك
والف مبروك على هذا النجاح
كيف حالك انا الحمد لله تمام انت احكي لي
عن مشاعرك لمن شفت انه الخلاط في العشر
الاوائل على مستوى السعوديه وبعدين العشره
الاوائل على مستوى العالم
يعني والله الحمد لله
يعني تفاجئنا باول كم ساعه من عرض
المنصه صار رقم واحد في السعوديه فطمنا
الحمد لله الذي وصل له يعني صدى عالمي بعد
خلال اول اسبوع
في الافلام الانجليزيه في العالم الحمد
لله ان العين على العمل والعين على
الصناعه كلها فخورين جدا جدا بالالف
الشخصي على هذا المشروع الجيش كامل
لمحمد
الانتاج الى الممثلين الى الكتاب الى
المنتجين يعني كانت خلقتنا حلو كان جيش
يعني الحمد لله
كميه الممثلين او النجوم اللي موجودين فيه
كثار وكلنا انا حتى كنت باقول لك قبل اله
انه كلهم صار لهم فتره بس شفناهم في هذا
الفيلم تحديدا بشكل مختلف كلهم وكانه كلهم
ممثلين يعني محترفين كيف تمت هذه
الاختيارات وكيف تم التعامل معهم لانه
حسيت كانه كلهم كده كانه قفزوا درجات
كثيره يعني في الاداء
يعني الحمد لله احنا من اكثر الاشياء اللي
محظورين فيها في التلفاز 11 هو وجودنا بين
كميه كبيره من المبدعين اللي في شبكه
من السعوديه ومن الخليج خلال 10 سنوات
اللي فاتت عملنا كثير محتوى على اليوتيوب
تعاوننا فيه مع الفنانين كثير في المنطقه
من ناحيه التعب ومخرجين ومنتجين وممثلين
فكل احد اشتغلنا معه عندنا عليه وكل مخرج
اشتغل مع ناس عيني عليهم اه الحمد لله
كميه زخم من الاعمال السعوديه اللي جالسه
تطلع من كل المنصهات وعلى السنه المكان
مغمورين ولا ما حصلت لهم الفرصه ولا لسه
ما حد اكتشفها يعني مسؤوليات هنا ومن اهله
مع هذه القدرات الحمد لله يعني كان يوتيوب
شو 22 حلقه من مجموعه
ممثلين كثير الحين زعلانين ما لحقنا يعني
نظهر كل احد ونتعامل مع كل احد
خلاط بلاس بلاس ولا
يعني باذن الله بس يعني التسميه هذه اتوقع
عندك اجزاء ولازم نوق
فه اوكي طيب كنت بدي اسالك كمان دائما
يقولوا انه في اعمال سعوديه بتنعرض موجوده
بعد الاحيان يمكن زي اي مجال يعني في جيد
في الممتاز في العادي وهكذا الباب بيقول
انه همم طيب طولوا بالكم يا جماعه لسه ما
حنوصل للمستوى اللي نافس فيه على مستوى
عالمي انتم اليوم بتثبتوا العكس همم لو
العكس في هذا الكلام بتحس انه هذه كلها
مقولات احباطيه يعني حجه انه ما تقدر نفسه
على المستوى العالم هذا
يعني لما احد يقول ما تقدروا نفسه نقول
طيب يعني انتهى النقاش بس افهم جدا
مسؤوليه اللي على كل صانع افلام وصانع
محتوى انه لا اذا ما في ثقه في المحتوى
السعودي في السينما مثلا ولا في مكان معين
ولا في المنصات ولا في ناس تتكلم عن
المستوى طبعا الصناعه جديده ورح تاخذ وقت
وهذا الشيء ما ناخذه على انه احباط او
تثبيت لا هذا مسؤوليات وتحدينا ابدا لما
الشخص يروح يشتري تذكره ويروح للسينما
واجب الحق علينا ان ما نعطيه كلنا كسرناه
افلام شيء ما يستاهل وقته ابدا ااه لكن
الحمد لله جاسمين نفهم الجمهور نفهم همم
يعني كسر نعرف افلام بشكل عام مش تلفاز
حتى صناعه السعوديه جالسه على نفسها
والمتابع السعودي ما شاف نفسه والمجتمع
ومواقف كثيره بشكل مستمر من زمان عن
الشاشه الكبيره فطبيعه تكون رده الفعل طلع
الاعمال كل عمل يبني الثقه بين المتابع
والمصانع الافلام والحمد لله يعني نفس
الوقت شفنا صطار
يعني خلال اربع اسابيع الحمد لله كان ما
زال الاول
طلعت اعمال الناس كلها جلسه بتتكلم عنها
الفتره هذه الاعمال السعوديه وعلى العموم
واضح ان الجمهور متعطش لانه كل رايح في
جالس بيحضر ويتفرج واضح انه حتى عالمين في
اهتمام بما انكم وصلتوا لقائمه اهم 10
افلام انا باشكرك جدا ودائما بتمنى لك
التوفيق محمد كل الاعمال لكم ان شاء الله
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]